joining us now retired Vegas
metropolitan Police Officer SWAT officer
Bob Lewis is with us Bob's daughter was
at the concert Sunday night he rushed
down to the shooting scene to find her
also with us Iraq war veteran Colin
Donahue Colin was attending the festival
on Sunday night when the gunman opened
fire
also joining us Tony ray bone his son
Nick
shot in the chest currently in ICU at
the hospital Nick's friend Billy Tufano
he's also with us he was at the concert
with Nick he helped save Nick's life and
we're also joined by Russell black and
he was at the concert taking videos of
this madness after the shooting started
let me start with you if I can Tony
first of all you someone shot in the
chest thank you for being how's he doing
he's doing very well now we were they
were able to take the breathing tube out
this afternoon
so he's been sitting up and speaking a
little bit and he had about two and half
hour surgery Sunday night but he's
through much better he said because he
was such a big strong kid that his
muscle actually helped save his life
yeah the surgeon said that he's not used
to operating on someone with text like
is a little problem it did yeah will
there be any lasting injury for him
fortunately no we don't think there will
be but you know when he came to - the
way thank God I know we do I really do
and he's a tremendous support his his
main concern though honestly when he
came to his little upset when he heard
that he's getting a lot of national
attention because he's a hockey coach
here at UNLV
hockey coach he's I played hockey
growing up I'm a big fan
so he's been getting a lot of attention
while he was under and when he woke up
he really was upset honestly because he
was saying you know there was 59 people
that died he goes I didn't do anything
my brother saved me Billy saved me he
goes it's it's really difficult for him
at this and I and I said well you know
all the people in the hospital and
everybody with has been totally amazing
yeah Billy you're his best friend by the
way you're a hero you're also a
paramedic right no no oh you're not
other Anthony that was with us he's the
paramedic paramedics
a fire department out here but you
helped him you helped save you buddy's
life that's gonna make you feel good for
the rest of your life we're grateful
that he's here that we were there with
him yeah absolutely yeah thank you for
what you did here
your daughter was there you hear about
this you've served in on the police
force how long 27 years 27 years 20 of
them on the SWAT team 20 on the SWAT
team you know how dangerous this
situation is she actually called me Sean
she was at the intersection of Las Vegas
Boulevard Mandalay Bay right she calls
me screaming petrified at 10:08
she says dad the police are making me
get down and I hear firecrackers she
goes it sounds like firecrackers I'm and
I'm hearing the rapid fire of an
automatic weapon I'm like Anneliese that
is not that is not firecrackers can you
see anything where this issue is no I'm
literally in a dog pile of people and
she goes a police car just pulled up to
block where they believe the shots were
coming from it's just she said I can't
get across the street now I said okay
stay down let me guess dad went running
well at that point Sean I was in
flip-flops shorts and a t-shirt and I
was already at my car in the driveway
but I didn't grab keys or anything I'm
pulling on the door because I'm so just
terrified yeah so you went back again
got you got when they got my gun my bag
and I jump back in the car and I got
down here and my at the whole time I'm
on the phone with her telling her what
to do and she's running and I'm telling
her I need to know which way you're
running which is that good with
directions but she's yelling out
landmarks she says I just passed the
building says Oasis I'm passing Haven
Street which is actually the street
we're on it just doesn't go through here
and then she says I'm running forward to
the building says video poker calm dad
Wow and the whole time I'm driving like
a lunatic to get down here and you
talking to her the whole the whole time
on my blue took it took me 53 minutes to
get to her Wow right yeah it was good
but the nice thing was as she was
running the gunfire was lessening I
could hear weakening so I knew she was
running my way almost 11 minutes scared
absolutely you know calling you you
served in Iraq I says what does it say
operation and hearing result I have neat
glass operation inherent resolve I got
back on September 7th you're at the
concert you know the sound
you knew it immediately Rodgers it
sounded like fireworks but at the same
time I was like I've heard this I've
heard the sounds before and it was kind
of it was surreal I turned around I
talked to
to my left and he dropped I looked at
him I'm like what you all right he's
like just shot me in the leg and I
looked I was like yep that is a bullet
hole
all right well put a finger on it and
people start everybody dropped on the
second volley and then once the volleys
ended they started I was trying to push
people to cover and concealment and once
we started clearing out the areas we
started doing some hasty triage trying
to make sure that people are all right
one of my friends Olivia and Belinda
Olivia's a nurse and so she followed me
around and we were verifying whether
people were breathin or not and then
doctors medics there were numerous
people there that were helping out and
it wasn't just me there was you were
able to help was your background in the
military Roger I was I worked with I
can't tell you where the military Roger
you know my friends would say yeah Roger
Hannity anything so all right well I
could - no I'm proud of you thank you
for your service yes sir and you were
able to help save lives
we tried good for you we definitely
tried and there were tons of tons of
other people that were doing the same
thing I was doing well so you were there
you see in this you're taking videos
what are you thinking is you're watching
this horror unfold just you solve people
dropping I mean we were in the VIP tent
closest to the shooter in the VIP tent
closest to the shooter when I heard the
first three rounds and I started
shooting video I was thought well I was
actually already shooting video the
concert was the last song so I thought
right back here yes sir I got it we just
it took us right over 15 minutes to get
out of the tent that's right behind you
you'd run one way and you just see
rounds hitting the ground and then you
just run the other way and then there
are 10-foot fences and people just we're
myself in a Maine
listen you're a hero you got out safely
thank God and helping other people thank
God you were there for your buddy I'm
glad your daughter's alright and we're
still praying for your son the UNLV
hockey coach you got to be proud of him
too you know and thank everyone yeah
everyone you're right everyone
absolutely Las Vegas Metro Police
Department did a fantastic job the first
responder met so many did amazing right
then absolutely and then all the other
people here jumping in when I was
running down Giles Street it looked like
a warzone triage everywhere and there
were so many people helping yelling cars
were being loaded up it was fantastic
I'm conflicted by being here because I
was fortunate I got to my daughters you
say but so many other people were hurt
and I've been in this city for 27 years
as a police officer you've never seen
any went then and we just we're gonna
get back to this video in a second here
and we saw that and then we heard the
scanner and and the cop saying ok we're
gonna have a breach or whatever breach
it's a little ok the guy that they're
breaching has a machine gun and those
everybody else is scattering they're
running to save life so there's a hero
there near us absolutely so you're
having 27 years of service all right